foreign
[Music]
so I'm super excited to be here
um so when I was starting College I was
super excited
um because I was going to be doing math
and science and I would just get to work
with equations and numbers and do
experiments and play with liquid
nitrogen and I would never have to write
anything ever again
um and I managed to make it through I
would say a lot of my undergraduate
career without that being too incorrect
which might say something about my
scientific education
but when I got to graduate school I
quickly realized that you couldn't just
do the science you actually also had to
talk about it
um and an excellent talk here in this
room yesterday by Louis kervin sometimes
you just need words
so I was super fortunate to have some
mentors who helped me learn how to write
and communicate tele narrative
um so I turned the corner and I'm okay
with writing now
I got a lot more practice at it so much
so now that if you work with me one of
the things as a part of onboarding to
work with me is that Hadley will tell
someone that my love language is Google
Docs
um so I was the open source program
director at rstudio now pause it if you
work with me expect to see a lot of
Google docs it's great to have just met
you Elliott expect some Google docs
um so I kind of I'm pretty squared away
on that
um but you know there's still
presentations and I do you know like
talking about ideas so I'll submit the
talk I'm super excited about it I'll
even write the talk and then when it
comes to doing the slides I am never
excited I'm never thinking like oh this
is going to be great I'm going to sit
down to do my slides I'll be able to put
stuff right where I want it on the slide
my data and code I'll just be able to
integrate it seamlessly into my slides
and if I make any changes no big deal
it'll just automatically update that has
not once been a thought that has gone
through my mind
until now until quarto so Corto is
making presentations fun again or for me
at least for the first time
I am so excited about Corto that I would
sing about it but that is not an area of
strength for me
um so instead I have the words to
favorite things and I'm going to revise
these words for Corto so you may be
familiar with this component of the song
uh again not an area of strength but it
is like kind of a good tune so like I
might accidentally sing
um so raindrops on roses and whiskers on
kittens bright copper kettles and warm
wool and mittens brown paper packages
tied up with string these are a few of
my
I do like most of those things
but I do also like Cordo
so raindrops on Rosas instead of
Raindrops on Roses I am going to talk
about visual edits
so I mentioned one of the things that I
found frustrating is that I couldn't
like figure out where I'm gonna put
stuff on my slides so this is a very
straightforward slide
um list item one two three
um but what I want to show you is how I
did this when I was creating this slide
so I have my code here
what is this video gonna play
there we go okay so I can switch to
visual I can see it here is Source or as
visual I can add in my list item here
switch back to Source there it is as
source
um and then if I render it it's going to
render right here in preview
so I can really integrate where I'm
writing my code and being able to see
things right away so that's a really big
deal for me because that's how I put my
slides together
all right whiskers on kittens kittens
are one of my favorites
but one of my other favorites is columns
and tables
so again when you're thinking about how
to construct your slides how you lay
things out is really important so if I'm
thinking oh what are some of my other
favorite things besides Cordo ice cream
top of the list are in Python I do like
both I'm so excited about posit
um least favorite things banana flavor
fine as a banana not a good flavor in
anything else I know people have
different opinions slamming doors Nails
on chalkboards locking keys in the car
to refer to Julia and Max's I have done
that I like still fear it actually
um
okay so what if I wanted to add another
column put in an image no big deal
and when I say no big deal let's take a
look at the code that goes along with
columns right this is pretty
straightforward we have hey we're going
to do some columns and then we have the
columns and the information that's in
them we can also change the column width
super easily so there's a lot of
flexibility in how we put things
together and again combined with that
visual editor let's try some stuff out
see how it looks I would almost say like
I've never had sort of this much power
of placement in my slides unless it was
like HTML tables but I know we're not
supposed to compare things to HTML so
forget I said that
so tables tables are another thing that
has never been a joyful experience in my
presentation creation so this is a table
I took some data from scraped reviews of
ice cream from a few different websites
and which are the most favorite ice
cream flavors
so I took this data and I put it into a
table this is just a cable table
so really not a lot of complexity to
this table but integrates straight in
with my slides
I can do a GT table so this is GT a
little cooler looking right it has a
little bit of color better formatting
these are really
um some of the like
fundamental things around GT I'm not
using all the fancy features here but
everything that's here is possible for
you so what I really love about any
system when we talk about like being
code burst and people are talking about
the UI is is what this makes possible so
like where you can start and then where
you can go with things is like only
limited by your imagination and how much
time you want to spend formatting
okay so great my slides are doing great
now I'm gonna have to give my
presentation
so bright copper kettles
um I like kettles fine I guess I like
tea I had to look up what a Copper
Kettle was actually
um but notes for the speaker
so that's another thing that you want as
a presenter so I did mention I don't
love the presentation component so when
I'm putting together a talk I actually
start with the notes
um and so it's really nice to be able to
have those notes there for me and then
build the slides actually kind of in the
reverse order
so here's just a regular sign a slide
with speaker notes slide content
um this is the code that would generate
that slide
and then this is what it looks like to
me as a speaker so I have the slide that
I'm talking about then I have the time
and then I have in that bottom right
where the speaker notes go and then my
next slide everything that you would
hope for as a speaker
and again I've just really appreciate
how it's all integrated into one
document so you're really working just
like start to finish in one place and
not having the context switch is has
been a really nice feature
okay and next we have warm Woolen
mittens I like normal admittance my
hands are always cold
um so code first keeps things stable
it's a bit of a stretch I had to rhyme
um
but this is really about what I referred
to at the beginning around the idea of
reproducibility so uh as Garrick
mentioned in my introduction I spent
many years teaching people about how to
work with data a code and a research
context good practices and so the
reproducibility component is is
essential when we're thinking about
scientific communication and So within
cuaro the slides the figure and the code
they're all integrated and so I've had
situations where I've put together a
presentation and I had a figure in that
presentation I wanted to use that figure
again but I couldn't actually remember
how I had generated that figure we don't
have that problem here right it's all
integrated together and so I think about
sharing things with collaborators but I
also especially think about sharing
things with future me because I don't
necessarily remember what passed me did
and passed me doesn't always make good
choices and so the more I can document
the more things are integrated the
easier it makes to to reproduce things
to share to communicate effectively and
accurately what we're doing especially
in our research context
so we can see here again this is just
straightforward ggplot code
and then here we have the graph that
this code generates here below just all
right together
so in general right I wouldn't show the
code necessarily along with the figure
but now if you go get the slides you
have right there the code that went into
the figure there's no questions about
what it was that I was communicating in
this talk and you probably really want
to know the relationship between the
average star rating and numbers of
reviews in ice cream flavors I wouldn't
say there's really any positive
particular Trends here I wouldn't do a
statistical analysis
okay next we come to brown paper
packages and this is very apt with
themes to Delight in
okay so themes to Delight in again kind
of a standard boring slide
um but we can easily change our themes
so I used the super exciting default
theme in this presentation
um Aesthetics are something I'm working
on as well
um and so you can see
it's gonna work play
yes okay but I can change the theme so
Cordo has some built-in themes
um dark being one of them
and so you see I re-render the theme
changes I'm ready to go I'm going to try
solarized which I actually really like
um that's another theme
so these are the built-in themes
um but again if we refer back to one of
the talks yesterday that said you know
something you really can do to help
yourself a lot is to build uh themes for
your organization for yourself that you
use time and again that match whatever
it is that you need to be doing for your
organization for yourself meet whatever
standards you need and so you could
spend a lot of time building your own
theme but I bet already people in this
room are starting to make amazing themes
and so the opportunity to share these
with each other and easily switch back
and forth is really meaningful because
I'm not spending time recreating my
slides every time I can just change the
theme and have a different look and feel
all right finally we're at tied up with
string and formats to share
so tied up with string is really the end
right you have your presentation you
need to share it
Mimi and Julie did a great job this
morning talking about all the different
formats that you can share in so this
here is an HTML presentation that's
great it works right in my browser I
didn't have any issues with that
um and it also is really good for
accessibility because you can make use
of all the things that are already built
into HTML around screen readers colors
so people are able to make use of the
settings that they have in their browser
already when you're sharing HTML
lots of times we do need PDFs to share
distribute print out and carry around
with us
so PDFs are something that is
straightforward from these as well again
all the same document creating all of
these different formats
and finally I really appreciate the work
that the Cordo team has put into making
PowerPoints there are a lot of
organizations that need to use
PowerPoints so if you are in one of
those organizations you are probably not
culturally going to be able to shift
your entire organization over to using
Corno one because culture change is hard
but two there are requirements and
government agencies and Drug Discovery
around the kinds of information that you
share and how you share it so I think
what we've talked about a lot in this
meeting is meeting people where they are
understanding what people need and
building towards that rather than saying
like oh you need to be doing this or
some idea of what's best is really
creating opportunities for people to do
what it is they need to do in their
context
um so PowerPoint is one you would change
in that header where we were changing
the theme you can at the beginning say
that you want a PowerPoint output and
you can make a PowerPoint output from
within quarto and again you have all
those advantages of being able to
integrate your code and your
visualization and you're not doing what
I did would be like get it out of her
put it into illustrator then take it
from illustrator and put it into
PowerPoint so those days are at least a
little bit behind me but looking ahead
I'm so excited about the opportunities
that this presents
so here we go this is how we've
Rewritten the Cordo song uh favorite
things for Corto
so
it does Rhyme all right so visual edits
columns and tables notes for the speaker
codes first keep slide stable Dean
student Lyden and formats to share these
are a few of my favorite things
I couldn't not sing it because I've
literally had it in my head for like two
weeks straight
um
so
um these are some places where you can
learn more there's a lot of
documentation on the quarter website
you've been sent there for a lot of
different reasons uh quarter
presentations this slide deck is in
GitHub if you want kind of the basics of
how to get started on things
um you should subscribe to the Glimpse
newsletter uh we had the first one come
out just a couple weeks ago we'll have
another one in August that'll have lots
about our tools and how to use them
especially after this meeting so I'm
just excited to be here for me it was
just such a joy to make this
presentation I so appreciate the work
the quarto team has done how they've
listened to people like me and thinking
about how they need to communicate their
results and I'm just so excited to see
what you do with quarto what you share
and what you communicate about to make
the changes that are important in your
work in your life in your communities
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]